lo que una vez fue el corazón del
movimiento de protesta de sri lanka
ahora se parece más a un campamento
militar al amanecer en colombo soldados
fuertemente armados montaban guardia en
el lugar donde horas antes habían
desalojado violentamente en los
manifestantes
que las tropas del gobierno vinieron dos
mil tropas vinieron aquí y bloquearon
todas las carreteras pusieron las
barreras y destruyeron nuestra tienda y
nuestra propiedad
siempre seremos pacíficos y lucharemos
hasta que este régimen de ramil
rajapaksa quede fuera de la historia
política sobre los manifestantes habían
ocupado el lugar durante los últimos
tres meses situado a las puertas de las
oficinas presidenciales había un símbolo
de desafío al gobierno de sri lanka
horas antes de que los manifestantes
tuvieran que abandonar la zona la
policía y los soldados entraron
golpeando a los manifestantes y a los
periodistas según los testigos el alza
de los precios del combustible y los
alimentos ha provocado grandes protestas
contra la élite gobernante del país que
llegaron a su punto álgido la semana
pasada cuando él presidente gotabaya
rajapaksa tuvo que huir después de que
los manifestantes irrumpieran en la casa
presidencial
el nuevo presidente de la ncaa running
we creeme single había prometido una
dura acción contra el movimiento de
protesta cuando fue elegido a principios
de esta semana el mandatario ya nombró
su gabinete que ahora tiene la tarea de
sacar a sí blanca de la crisis económica